A heap is another specific type of tree
with some of its own additional rules.
In a heap, elements arranged in
increasing or decreasing order
such that the root element is either the
maximum or minimum value in the tree.
There are two different types of heaps.
Max heaps and min heaps that
capture those two situations.
In a max heap, a parent must always
have a greater value than its child so
the root ends up being
the biggest element.
The opposite is true of min heaps, a
parent has a lower value than its child
so the root is the minimum element.
Heaps don't need to be binary trees, so
parents can have any number of children.
Operations like search, insert and
delete can vary a lot based on
the type of heap we're discussing.
Here, I'm going to focus
on a max binary heap.
We're going to keep
the two children rule and
the root will be the maximum element.
In addition,
a binary heap must be a complete tree,
meaning all levels except
the last one are completely full.
If the last level isn't totally full,
values are added from left to right.
The right most leaf will be empty
until the whole row has been filled.
In this heap,
a function that gets the maximum value,
also called peek,
happens in constant time.
Let's see what search looks like.
Should we start our search by
going to the left or the right?
In a BST, we knew which direction to
go at each step by doing comparisons.
Here there's no guarantee either way.
Thus, searching ends up being a linear
time operation since normally,
we can't rely on tricks and
we'll end up searching the entire tree.
One thing to note is that we can
actually use the maxi properties to our
advantage in a search.
For example, we can quit our search
immediately if the element we're
searching for is bigger than the root.
In general,
if our node value is bigger than
the one we're comparing to, we don't
need to check anything in its sub-tree
since we know that it's the biggest.
The worst case remains but
in the average case,
we don't actually need
to search every element.
The average case is
closer to n over two but
that's still approximated
to linear time.